you always grill a burger always yup
best way to grill a burger cast iron
pot not a george farmer if i go by two
chains
two chains i'm over the top sometimes
wow
and right now we're going to check out
the most expensive [ __ ]
it's definitely crazy what up what up
it's 2 chainz and we back
most expensive is [ __ ] and today we're
going to talk about something that
actually made the guinness book of world
records
a damn hamburger serendipity new york
city
this burger right here costs more than
your iphone let's do it
smells good in here boy joe joe what's
up my man
how you doing damn that's a big ass
burger this is the guinness world record
most expensive burger in the world the
berger extravagant from serendipity 3.
what's the name of it again
the burger extravagant because i'm a
rapper and i need to be able to
where did this idea come from are you
just a natural burger lover well i
created this
for uh national hamburger month it's not
just about expensive
it's not good through trial and error we
came up with this japanese wagyu beef
infused with white truffle butter and 10
herbs we have a 24 karat gold dusted
bun real gold on there you can eat
though you can eat gold and of course
right on top it's like a gold and
diamond toothpick
the cheese is aged for how long 18
months in a cave
why on the cake the humidity the perfect
conditions cool
i always wanted to go on a cave these
truffles are announced
uh shave black truffles summer truffles
from italy
even the ketchup is special ketchup is
heirloom tomato ketchup
it's a lot to to take in then we got
caviar that's what kaluga caviar kaluga
it's the most expensive caviar in the
world
how much is that 200 an ounce
for the caviar yes that's about a gram
yeah how much for this hamburger
295
with or without tax or fries
or price you can't get that and it comes
with a drink or anything like that no no
no
you can't super size it either it's not
only the most expensive it's the best
taste
okay to go the caviar the cheese is made
in the cake yeah
the quail egg that's dropped from
[ __ ] mars
i want to try you have a knife or
something i want you to take your
toothpick
off put the caviar on top okay in terms
of how to eat the most expensive this is
so
dope here goes nothing man
i just ate some gold
[Music]
look at that so how often do you make
this 300 burger it's
with 28 hour notice because we have all
these ingredients flown in
just for your burger if i were to tell
you i was full how much would you charge
me
the nice thing about this is all the
profits go to the bowery mission
uh to feed and house the homeless in new
york city not only are you
getting the best in the world but you're
doing something good yeah um
joe i'm gonna be honest with you this
burger was more than just food it was an
experience for me i mean i eat very well
i have a chef with me at all times but
this is a whole nother level i'm gonna
have to challenge my chef to order some
things
from a cave eileen you gotta go to the
cave but
and i don't know about you but if you
would have bit that [ __ ] burger
you would feel the same way i feel my
life has changed
all the proceeds go to feed the homeless
it's a good guy
makes the best burger i've ever had in
my life but do you think it's worth
it leave a comment subscribe to the gq
channel
for more most expensive [ __ ] you tell me
what's the problem